♪
>> WELCOME BACK TO THE BIG
SUNDAY SHOW.
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID TO MEET
WITH CHINESE PRESIDENT TOMORROW
XI JINPING AS HE PUSHES HIS
CLIMATE AGENDA OVERSEAS.
BIDEN SAID HE IS NOT CHANGING A
THING AFTER THE MIDTERMS.
>> WHAT IN THE NEXT TWO YEARS DO
YOU INTEND TO DO DIFFERENTLY TO
CHANGE PEOPLE'S OPINION OF THE
DIRECTION OF THE COUNTRY AS YOU
PLAN TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT IN
2024.
>> NOTHING.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE DOUBLED DOWN
WHILE PROMISING MORE OF ONE
THING, SPENDING.
>> A LOT OF COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY HAVE NOT FELT THE
EFFECTS ON THIS YET BECAUSE IT
TAKES A LITTLE TIME TO IMPLEMENT
THESE THINGS.
THE PRESIDENT LIKES TO SAY, THEY
HAVE NOT FELT IT YET.
THE DEBT CEILING NEEDS TO BE
LIFTED, IT NEEDS TO HAPPEN
AGAIN.
OBVIOUSLY, SOMETIME NEXT YEAR.
>> I HAVE A FEELING THAT THE
FLOODGATES ARE ABOUT TO OPEN ON
SPENDING AND A WHOLE LOT OF
OTHER THINGS.
I WANT TO REVISIT OUR
CONVERSATION YESTERDAY.
THIS ELECTION WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
A REFERENDUM ON THEIR HORRIBLE
POLICIES.
THE MAJORITY OF AMERICANS ARE
NOT HAPPY WITH WHAT IS GOING ON
IN THE COUNTRY.
THEY STILL VOTED DEMOCRAT.
IS IT NOW.
MY HEAD OR DO YOU THINK THERE
WILL BE A PAUSE?
MAYBE A COMP TO JESUS MOMENT
WHERE DEMOCRATS SAY, YOU KNOW,
WE ONE, THE PEOPLE ARE STILL
UNHAPPY.
DO WE HAVE ANY HOPE FOR THINGS
LIKE THAT OR ARE WE JUST OUT OF
LUCK?
>> I WOULD LOVE TO THINK THAT
DEMOCRATS ARE SMART ENOUGH TO DO
THAT.
OUT LIKE TO THINK THEY ARE LIKE
THE OLD DEMOCRATIC PARTY IN
BROOKLYN.
THAT IS NOT WHO WE HAVE TODAY.
NO INDICATION THAT THEY HAVE
LEARNED ANYTHING.
JOE BIDEN SAID NO CHANGE.
CHUCK SCHUMER SAID HE FELT A
GREAT VINDICATION ABOUT NOT
LOSING AS BADLY AS HE THOUGHT HE
WOULD.
THESE PEOPLE, THEY ARE IN
DENIAL.
I DO NOT THINK THEY WILL CHANGE
ANYTHING.
THE ONLY SORT OF MESSAGE OUT OF
THIS IS THAT REPUBLICANS FAILED
TO MAKE THE CASE.
WHEN YOU GO THROUGH WHETHER IT
IS CRIME OR INFLATION OR GAS
PRICES, THERE IS NO QUESTION
ABOUT THE RESULTS, ABOUT THESE
ISSUES AND HOW THEY ARE A DIRECT
RESULT OF THESE POLICIES.
THE FAILURE WAS FOR REPUBLICANS,
FAILING TO MAKE THE CASE THAT
WILL FIX THIS.
>> JACKIE, I WANT TO ASK YOU
ABOUT THIS ARE STILL WAITING TOT
THE SHAKEUP WILL BE WHAT THE
NUMBERS.
NOW, EVEN IF WE DO HAVE A
MAJORITY IN THE HOUSE, DO WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO
ANYTHING TO SHOW THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THAT REPUBLICANS HAVE
SOLUTIONS?
IS THERE ANYTHING WE CAN DO WITH
A SLIM MAJORITY NOR MAJORITY AT
ALL HEADING INTO 2024?
HEY, WE CAN DO SOMETHING ABOUT
THIS.
>> WHAT WALL STREET PRAYS THIS
WEEK WITH THAT DAY ON THE DOW
WAS IF REPUBLICANS DO TAKE THE
HOUSE, AT LEAST THEY CAN BLOCK
MORE SPENDING OR THEY CAN BLOCK
THAT CLIMATE CHANGE AGENDA AT
LEAST A LITTLE BIT.
THEY DO SEE PRESIDENT BIDEN
COMING ON INTO THE WORLD STAGE
AND BEING DEFIANT.
I DO THINK IT WAS ABOUT A PLAN
AND NOT NECESSARILY HAVING THAT
PLAN OR BEING CLEAR ABOUT WHAT
IT ENTAILED.
BUT I ALSO THINK IT WAS ABOUT
ISSUES.
ABORTION BECAME A MUCH BIGGER
ISSUE THAN ANYONE ANTICIPATED.
I AM REALLY WORRIED ABOUT
INFLATION, BUT I CARE ABOUT
ABORTION MORE.
THAT IS HOW THEY VOTED.
OR THE YOUNG PEOPLE THAT CAME
OUT TO VOTE IN THE PROMISE THAT
THEIR STUDENT LOANS, 10-30,000
DOLLARS WILL BE FORGIVEN.
I LIKE FREE STUFF SO I WILL GO
IN THIS DIRECTION.
I THINK THAT THEY ARE SOME
CAVEATS THAT THE REPUBLICANS
WERE NOT NECESSARILY
ANTICIPATING.
IF YOU SEE THE REPUBLICANS
GETTING THE HOUSE AS THEY
ANTICIPATED IN A BLOCK SPENDING,
MAYBE WE HAVE A CHANCE TO TRY TO
GET OUT OF SOME OF THIS.
>> ALL EYES ON INTERNATIONAL
RELATIONS THAT BIDEN HAS FUMBLED
ON IF YOU JUST HAVE I SAID
YEARS.
BIDEN IS FEELING MIGHTY
CONFIDENT.
>> I KNOW HIM WELL.
HE KNOWS ME.
WE HAVE VERY LITTLE
MISUNDERSTANDING.
WE JUST HAVE TO FIGURE OUT WHERE
THE RED LINES ARE.
>> IT'S A GOOD TIME TO BE CHINA,
I'M JUST GOING TO SAY THAT.
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON WHAT YOU
WILL SEE TOMORROW?
ARE WE COMING IN FROM A POSITION
OF STRENGTH OR HIS CHINA
LAUGHING AT US ALONG WITH THE
REST OF THE WORLD?
>> PROBABLY WOULD NOT START
REGURGITATING THE REDLINE POLICY
MAYBE HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF
INSIGHT INTO HOW PEOPLE RESPOND
TO THAT.
WE CANNOT GET ENOUGH PEOPLE TO
SERVE, OUR MILITARY HAS HOLES IN
IT STRATEGY ALL OVER WITH OUR
CYBERSECURITY TO EVEN OUR
PACIFIC FLEET.
WE ARE TRYING TO ATTACK OUR OWN
ECONOMY UNDER THE VIRTUE OF
GREEN ENERGY.
I DO NOT KNOW HOW ANY OF THAT
CREATES STRENGTH.
WHEN WE LOOK AT OUR OWN
ADVERSARIES, WHAT WE CALL
STRENGTH AMONG THEM AND WHEN
THEY LOOK AT US, WHAT DO WE DO
TAP THE SAME STRENGTHS WASHER
MARK I THINK ENERGY POLICY IS A
BIG ONE.
NATIONAL PATRIOTISM.
DO THE PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY
STILL WANT TO FIGHT FOR IT?
WE ARE IN A BAD PLACE AND ALL OF
THEM.
>> ARE WE WILLING TO FIGHT THE
FIGHTS, IS ANOTHER QUESTION
WILLING TO BE HAD.
JAPAN IS UPSET RIGHT NOW.
WE HAVE CHINA, WE HAVE RUSSIA,
WE HAVE UKRAINE.
ALL OF OUR ENEMIES ARE GETTING
STRONGER.
I GUESS THAT IT WILL REMAIN TO
BE SEEN.
WHAT IS OUR BIGGEST NATIONAL
SECURITY THREAT?
IS IT ELON MUSK COORS AT THE
NATIONAL SECURITY THREATS THAT
WE FACE?
>> OUR BIGGEST NATIONAL SECURITY
THREAT IS OUR OWN CULTURE.
>> PRESIDENT XI JINPING GETTING
ELECTED IN HIS THIRD TERM.
HE HAS WATCHING IT AND SAYING
TH